We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. so
this voicemail relates to a video I played
for you yesterday, in which maybe the most
illusional Trump supporter we've ever encountered
said that he's with Trump because of family
values and integrity of character and so on
and so forth.
And we said family values and Trump, that
doesn't seem to make any sense.
This caller who called our, our voicemail
number says, we're not understanding what
Republicans mean by family values.
Take a listen to this.
Yeah, I can't believe you don't already know
this.
When Republicans talk about family values,
uh, that means, Oh, I hate gays.
I hate abortion.
I hate birth control.
I hate women's rights.
I hate marijuana legalization and I'm gonna
put as many pot smokers in jail if that's,
that's their family values right there.
Right.
I guess I just misunderstood when, when that
Trump voters said he's with Trump because
of his family values.
I guess I was thinking of reasonable family
values, but if you go by that, here's the
thing.
Even if you go by that Trump is lying.
I mean, listen, Trump's been for a woman's
rights, a women's rights when it comes to
abortion.
For his entire life until he started running
for president.
Uh, Trump is for contraception.
He's only pretending in the least believable
possible way to have changed his mind on those
things.
But maybe you're right.
Maybe the color is absolutely right about
this.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about another one of these supposedly
inspirational stories.
This one is about a McDonald's employee who's
92 and still working.
I find the story to be dystopian, not an inspirational
story.
We will also talk about Prince Charles looking
at reducing the number of Royals and what
[inaudible],
what's behind them, what it would mean, and
much more great bonus show today.
Hope to speak to you though, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.